is there any institution that Americans
can still trust act on their behalf and
not on behalf of powerful special
interests that's the question joining me
now Tulsi gabbard former Hawaii
congresswoman 2020 presidential
candidate and Fox News contributor hello
Tulsi welcome hi Kaylee thank you you
know that it seems as if the little guy
if you will always is responsible for
the big guy the big guy always gets the
preferential treatment whether it's
bailing out a Chinese investor whether
it's the Community Banks paying in
special assessments that bail out
Silicon Valley why is that
there's this revolving door and Kaylee I
know you're very very familiar with
where constantly we see how for example
members of Congress who are supposed to
be regulating big Pharma don't and then
they go and leave Congress and get a big
payout from Big Pharma we see it with
the military-industrial complex uh
secretary Austin then General Austin
retires in the military goes and works
for Raytheon now goes back as a
secretary of defense and seeing the
billions of dollars that is going
towards the military-industrial complex
we see those these Financial Regulators
people who are in positions to actually
do their job to protect the little guy
to protect our small and Community Banks
but instead what are they doing they're
looking for that payout where they can
go and work for the big banks that they
are allowing off the hook it's this
incredible abuse of power that that
voids that that that trust that that
you're talking about here and and it's
frankly this is the thing that needs to
be fixed I look back to the Declaration
of Independence where our Founders very
directly recognized the propensity for
abuse of power for those who start to
get some and so they told us hey those
in power derive their power from the
consent of the governed and that's where
as we look at how do we fix this mess
where is there any hope to be found
through the consent of the governor that
means every one of us has this
incredible responsibility to oversee
those who we place in power to hold them
accountable when they are abusing those
positions and elect those who truly take
that responsibility seriously of serving
the American people upholding the
Constitution putting the interests of of
the American people first so speaking of
you say consent of the governed they
don't seem to have
sent at the moment we have the numbers
we'll
we'll for you the level of trust in
institutions is remarkably low U.S
government GOP is 35 trust Democrats 63
percent Congress 40 percent Republicans
54 percent Democrats as you can see
there's definitely falling trust among
Republicans specifically but even you
know Wall Street Democrats 46 percent uh
there's just distrust broadly
yeah there is like you know for me I
think one of the only institutions that
I think we can trust right now is the
the Supreme Court serving as a check on
on a lot of this abuse of power uh but
ultimately what it comes down to the
only one that we can really trust uh is
God and and once again our Founders
really recognize this and put these
systems in place specifically uh for We
the People to ensure that this country
belongs to us and that we do have uh the
opportunity and that responsibility to
ensure that our government is of by and
for the people so all this erosion of
trust that you're seeing in those
numbers that you just cited that comes
from the fact that we have far too many
corrupt politicians far too many corrupt
unelected bureaucrats who we don't know
what their names are but they are
operating behind uh you know in the dark
behind the curtains in the shadows
essentially changing laws and making
decisions that affect us in our everyday
lives for their own benefit and we have
no way to hold them accountable uh so we
do this by taking action through those
who we choose to hire and fire through
this system that our Founders created
for us which is still the best system in
the world I couldn't agree more with you
especially when it comes to God just a
few moments here but it's ironic to me
that God someone you can trust is who is
being run out of society we know he was
an integral part of our founding
mentioned in many of our founding
documents separation of church and state
found nowhere in our founding documents
however it's been utilized to create a
religion of secularism do you think it's
doing damage the fact that we are
erasing broadly God out of a society in
a way perhaps our Founders never
intended there's no question about it
Kayla you see this erosion of this
spiritual Foundation of our country as a
direct consequence of those who are
trying to erase God from from just about
every facet of our public lives this is
one of the main reasons why I chose to
leave the Democratic party because I saw
increasingly how not only were they
trying to erase God from or any mention
of God or uh you know attacking people
of Faith attacking people of
spirituality especially Christians you
see these attacks and you see the
consequences in the direction
unfortunately that much of our our
country is headed in and the Damage it's
causing to families to children so to
our communities
um to to our policy makers many of whom
think that they are God and are trying
to control Us in every possible way it's
so true Tulsi so much wisdom from you
always have a great Saint Patrick thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else